here's what would happen if the Earth  was spinning at the speed of light if  the Earth rotated at a speed of nearly  300 000 kilometers per second that would  be 652  000 times faster than it spins today the  dimensions of our planet would change  once a sphere the Earth would contract  into a thin disk-like shape rotating at  this extreme speed would distort time on  Earth it would slow down so much that it  would eventually stop you would freeze  in time so hopefully you'd be caught in  a good moment Earth could become a tiny  black hole that's because an object  moving at the speed of light has an  infinite Mass nothing and no one would  be making it out of this situation alive  so let's hope the Earth's rotation  doesn't speed up because